i mean no because like i i feel like i
guess watching a lot of j
drums reminds me of like the old
thai soap operas i would see my mom
watching and i'm just like what the [ __ ]
is this mom
like what the hell are you watching i
feel like the indian shows as well yeah
i feel like that just
i feel like that's just a genre of
itself
where you got like the campiest most
melodrama [ __ ] going on
you don't know what's going on you see
out of context clips i think i think
even some korean dramas do this as well
it's just not as well known like
i remember seeing one clip where it was
a korean drama
and somebody's falling down the stairs
no that's the bollywood one that's right
i think that's the bollywood indian one
the one i was thinking of where this
this woman this guy says something and
his woman takes this entire like
[ __ ] cabbage of kimchi and just slaps
this guy
with it and i just like i just want to
know the context of this that's
because context it just makes no sense
we just have to remind our audience that
this is a korean production
bring out the kimchi
didn't like uh didn't pewdiepie react to
like a bollywood clip and then there was
like drama or something about it like
they're like
i swear there was draw i don't know if
man if i'm remembering this incorrectly
but like he
there was like a clip that he reacted to
and it was because there was like a
reaction image where she was like
and then it was like 20 shots of going
like zooming in yeah it's the woman
falling off like the bell straight right
is that oh i've seen that one the guy's
like slow motion trying to catch him but
like it's like
going back and forth and it's like this
woman's been in the air for five minutes
it's the second floor why is this
woman's like literally [ __ ] air
bending right in front of my eyes
everyone's just like watching it in slow
motion it's [ __ ] hilarious i love
that i
swear i swear she got into some spat or
something because
you keep talking yeah yeah no that's
what
i i would love to react to indian like
soap operas out of
context yeah i feel like there's every
other soap opera and then there's just
indian soap operas oh yeah yeah
they take campiness to the next level
and it's so amazing
have you ever have you ever seen like
many bollywood movies
there was a period in my life where i
tried to get into bollywood movies but
the problem is that
there are so many [ __ ] films in the
bollywood likes
i didn't realize how many movies they
made like it's like they make like
[ __ ] like five ten times as much as
like hollywood right yeah
it's insane so i'm just like i
legitimately was like
where the [ __ ] do i even begin because
like i don't know anybody else who like
has stepped into that territory
yeah so like my only other option was to
like go on the internet be like
best holy bollywood movies right top 10
bollywood films of all time
films thank you mojo here's my watch
list right now but then every [ __ ]
like top 10 top 50 list i saw
was just like all completely there
wasn't a single like
entry where it was like oh i saw that on
this page it's all [ __ ] different so
i'm like
what do i just have to like number five
yeah do i literally don't know you man
do i literally just have to like
that's a great movie though i remember
when that came out he was like i
something like bollywood millionaire
that's good it's good yeah so i'm like
do i just have to like bite the ball and
just like pick a random one
and just like hope that it's a good
movie i don't know yeah i don't know i
think please let us know in the comments
what's a good bollywood film
the only one i can remember that i
watched i think it's really good um
there's a film called three idiots
and the only reason i watched it was
because it was on the imdb top 100 at
the time
right i was like what is this and it's
it's a concept i i feel like that was
made for indians right
because it's a con it's a film get this
about engineers
and i think i think it was like actual i
can't remember if they were mechanical
engineers or electrical engineers
it doesn't matter they're engineers it
was just so weird seeing this
engineering movie and then out of
nowhere they just break out into song
and dance
like there's nothing i hate more than
[ __ ] musicals
i cannot stream like musicals i hate
musicals i i
actually agree with chris really yeah
it's like if i want a musical i'll
[ __ ] pause the movie
and go on spotify and play damn for four
minutes and i'll probably
i don't get in the way man i i hate i
hate musicals so
god damn much i cannot i would rather do
anything else
i'm like i'm very hit or miss with
musicals
like a lot of musicals i'm just like
[ __ ] whatever but then if you like
like i could
watch like rocky horror like 30 times i
feel like muse
i feel like to me musical works well on
like
when it's a stage you know when it's
when oh yeah when you're watching it
live
it's a really really amazing experience
like i remember watching lesbians of
robs
[ __ ] which is less miserables there's
miserables
um i remember watching that uh in
england at the west end
[ __ ] amazing experience yeah um and
then i remember watching the movie and
i'm just like this is
really boring i don't know i i watched
it for the first time because
like like pretty recently just because
aki was like oh you have to watch it
it's like it's great like i'm just like
okay well you know i always give
musicals a go so it's whatever
this this might be the rare time where
like rocky horror where it's like oh my
[ __ ] fall in love with it
i'm just like god damn that they haven't
stopped singing for like
two hours it just feels like a [ __ ]
quick time event like when you're in a
musical
it's like i guess i'll press x [ __ ] i'll
press x
it just feels like it doesn't [ __ ]
end it's like unskippable cut scenes and
[ __ ] it's like get the [ __ ] out of here
well what i like about like rocky horror
for instance right is that like one it's
[ __ ] weird
two it's [ __ ] tim curry in like
leggings
which is just like amazing just
conceptually yeah but like what i like
about rocky hard compared to like say
like les les miserables is like les
miserables just like
90 singing and then 10 dialogue
whereas rocky horror is like 50 50. so
it's like you get the enjoyment of like
an
actual movie like type of story every
now and then it goes into like song
but when i'm watching a musical i'm just
like just get to the story why why
why am i here i don't care about the
song and dance just get to the story
give me the story the only time actually
i actually think i liked musical was um
what is it there's a little little shop
of horrors right that has like a lot of
music in it the one with the big plan
oh yes this is yes that's musical right
yeah yeah yeah i think i like that
because it made the thing [ __ ]
terrifying when it started singing
i was like it sold me on the horror
because when there's this giant plant
puppet started singing i was getting
[ __ ] is it like a 15 year old kid like
holy [ __ ] it's like they're kind of like
jazzy styled like
yeah yeah it's terrifying
did you have uh did you ever watch bugs
me alone as a kid but what
what's him alone i know the name yeah i
don't know anything about it though
yeah it's uh i can't remember because i
only have vivid
memories of watching as a kid all i know
it was like it's like
set in like you know in the prohibition
era right uh
and it's about a bunch of people running
speakeasies but for some reason
everyone every one of the gangsters who
are you know
who are in this movie everyone's played
by kids right and
when they have tommy guns instead of
firing bullets
they fire like a cream pie so whenever
someone gets hit by a cream pie in the
face
they're dead it's like thinking back as
a kid
it's the most like this is the weirdest
fever dream
i'm describing right now but it exists
right
it sounds like a david lynch film you
know it's like it's like that weird
it sounds like on the same level what
are those [ __ ] dogs called the movies
where they
like they just dub over dogs it's
literally like air buddy or some [ __ ]
it's like a whole [ __ ] series oh like
snow dogs like that level yeah
look at this stuff like that where they
just [ __ ] dub over dogs doing [ __ ] i
got what the [ __ ]
dude oh my god i've been trying to find
someone else in my life who also has
this vivid memory of watching bugs me
alone as a kid
because i just want to reconfirm that i
that was real i don't think that this
was real it really happened
i just need to know okay and i so far
i've
you know maybe it was just my school
thing maybe it was
my generation thing i don't know but i
have not met a single other person
irl who remembers watching bugs me alone
so please comment section
if there's someone in the comments
section who knows and who has watched
buxy malone before
please please tell me because i need to
know i'm not [ __ ] crazy
i need to know this wasn't i need to
know this wasn't a fever dream
i need to know if this really happens
everyone in the comments just be like i
have no idea i have no idea
i don't have no
though did you guys watch the cats movie
no i didn't
i didn't i saw how did you watch it
because i was just like because i
who doesn't look at that trailer and
thinks this looks like [ __ ] i'm gonna
watch it
you know when you uh you just see ads so
often for something
that you've decided that you've decided
you're gonna dislike this thing before
you even see anything
that was me with cats because it was
just everywhere it was so obnoxious and
they do that thing where like
this has never been done before yeah
this is this has literally never been
done before like they just say that
about anything like
we've never had this we've never
experienced this we all felt amazing on
the set well the thing is with cancer
the thing is with cats is that i've seen
it uh on stage before
yeah and like i actually thought not my
favorite musical but i was like okay out
of all the musicals i've seen on stage
it's pretty alright it's pretty decent
like it's good story the songs are
pretty alright
but then when you watch that trailer and
you see the horrific things in that
trailer you're just like
well i've you have piqued my interest
now yes
[ __ ] green screen like huge artists
like on these like [ __ ] cat
like basically these huge actors being
furries i swear there was like
displays i said that was like really
funny like cached interviews
really well like the cast were like i
don't [ __ ] know
what do you want to say